[Music]
Sharna Burgess taking et to her first
ever true sculpt flex session true skull
flex is this awesome machine that is
about muscle building and sculpting it's
like you get the results of a hit
workout we know that you are fit you
workout you are on Dancing with Stars
forever so how does this compare to a
dance workout it's a completely
different things so dancing targets a
lot of different muscles especially
Dancing with the Stars moving another
person around our back muscles get very
toned but doesn't necessarily target the
lower abs as much drew sculpt flex
flexes those hard to get areas for the
34 year old each session takes 45
minutes and it works fast how many
treatments does it take for you to see
those results that you're going after so
it takes like say four to six treatments
but you could do two a week so
essentially in two to three weeks you
could be seeing results how much does
this set somebody back well the average
cost is somewhere between 3500 and 4000
dollars for eight applicators to be used
in four treatments is there a long
recovery process no there's no downtime
whatsoever should we do this procedure
yes let's do it I'm excited
[Music]
first of all how are you feeling you
feeling good like I'm in the middle of
an obsession yeah I'm noticing that
there are contractions happening
what exactly is is going on well this is
that proprietary technology its
contracting her core she's basically
doing a workout sitting here is she
getting the actual strength that you
would get from a workout you can
actually get the strength I mean this
device is really unique it has three
different modes there's the prepping
mode the tawny mode and the sculpting
right now we're sculpting so when she's
sculpt you should get the most
tightening what does it feel like right
now and that's happening it's like it's
like my muscles are soup if you like I'm
holding a like a V position
will she be in pain after this like will
you feel like you've worked out you do
feel like you worked out because it's
basically doing crunches for you and
it's stimulating the muscles after the
treatment though Sharna says she was
ready to hop a flight and felt no pain
and I'm not surprised you who are you
were doing this I think for me it was
just like how much it really truly
contracts my muscle I could feel them
getting like fatigued could you see any
definition starting divorce it was
apparent immediately will you work out
today no today I will not this is my
workout today
[Music]